hey everyone it's Mike and I just wanna
tell you about a webinar I got coming up
on Tuesday July 10th at 1:30 p.m.
Eastern Time and what are we talking
about is identifying market turning
points as they happen in the order flow
now this webinar that I'm doing is part
of the investor inspiration workshop
I'm the fourth speaker on the day so
even though the present the whole
workshop starts around I think 10 a.m.
I'm not speaking until 1:30 now again a
registration is free and if you sign up
if you can't make it just sign up and
I'll send you a link to the replay once
it becomes available now what I'll be
talking about in this presentation is
what you need to know about using order
flow to see the market turns as they
happen you know it's all about trading
in the present lots of people you know
when they come to trading they like to
throw up indicators on their on their
charts and you know that they're trading
on what's happened in the past and you
know is that right is that wrong you
know I prefer to trade on based on
what's happening right now not not
what's happened long ago and I will show
you some high percentage order flow
trade setups I'm going to talk about new
developments in order flow analysis so
you know just really quick I sent an
email out about this if you're not on my
email list you would not have gotten
this email but well you know one of the
trade high high percentage trade setups
I'll be talking about is how to read the
order flow Delta and how to use it in
your trading now you can see here this
is just on Friday July 6th in the e
Mini's just right after the cash open
8:30 the cash open and you know we're
selling off we're selling off here on
the open you see all negative Delta's
boom boom boom boom boom you got some
big ones - 1000 - 800 but then you would
get down into this low the swing low
here and we start to rally and as we're
rallying we're seeing positive Delta
getting stronger and stronger and
stronger and you know this is a sign in
the market based on what's happening now
that the market is seeing aggressive
buyers coming into the market and when
you're seeing aggressive buyers coming
into the market getting stronger the
market has a tendency to start to rally
its markets not going to sell off if you
have aggressive buyers coming in more
and more and more and
it's how to what I'll be talking about
is you know how to use the tools or the
information rather in the order flow to
you know to add value to your training
to help your training you know take it
to the next level
so again if you're interested in this
webinar you can go down into the
description I put the link in the
description just click on that it takes
you to the sign up page and again
remember sign up is free it's free to
attend and you know again if you can't
make it that's fine as long as you sign
up you'll be sent a link for the replay
once it's available so thanks everybody
and I hope to see you there on Tuesday
bye bye